we have more now of our interview with
Meredith Watson telling the story she
revealed after dr. Vanessa Tyson
publicly alleged that Virginia
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax
sexually assaulted her
Watson claims that fairfax raped her in
2000 when they were both students at
Duke University
she and Tyson say they have never met
Justin Fairfax denies their allegations
adamantly so Watson says that the me2
movement gave her hope that her voice
would finally be heard she also believes
her past is getting unfair attention you
know the thing you keep hearing from
most men certainly after the me2
movement is that a woman can make a
charge and a man has no defense and when
we get into your word against his
why are you more credible than he is I
don't have any gate thing to gain by
coming forward the only thing coming
forward has done is invited criticism
and chaos and scrutiny of me and put me
under a microscope and it's been
difficult enough what I've gone through
the last 20 years
I didn't eat this but I had to tell the
truth because they're been published
reports about an ex-boyfriend who took
out a peace order which is a form of a
restraining order in the state of
Maryland he claims he damaged his car
did you threaten to commit suicide that
you held him hostage and you know when
you talk about your past being
scrutinized that is certainly something
that's been brought up that you have
financial problems that you involved in
a messy relationship with the father of
your daughter how do you respond to
those allegations what does that have to
do with what happened to me in 2000 I
don't I don't want to give breath to the
smears that were put out whether they're
truth or lies I don't want to give power
to Justin and what he's done and put an
act like I have to defend myself I don't
have to defend myself because nothing in
my life that happened after that night
is relevant to what happened
you've written in The Washington Post
women of color who report rape know to
expect a dismissive response
characterized by an even greater
disbelief and more abuse if not complete
and utter indifference what did you mean
by that there's this expectation that we
are supposed to protect our black men at
all costs and there's been this idea
that black women I guess maybe because
this has happened to us throughout
history that it's just something we're
supposed to grin and bear and you keep
it going do you think these stories are
different when black women bring these
charges against black men absolutely
because you're seen as betraying a race
you know you're seeing us betraying
black men but there's no recognition
that a black man has betrayed you what
is it that you want as you sit here
today and you're sharing your story with
us I want some action from the Virginia
legislature I will say this there's
there is no amount of money they could
never compensate for what he did to me
or what I live with every day
are you seeking money no you're not
seeking no no I just want I want I want
to support dr. Tyson I want the people
of Virginia to know the truth and I
would like the Virginia legislature to
do the right thing
so when you saw Vanessa Tyson's
allegation you thought what I broke down
into tears because I felt guilty why do
you feel guilty it happened to her after
it happened to me
and had I had the strength or the
courage to say something in 2000 maybe
it never would have happened and I know
the pain nobody should have to go
through this
let's go awful now lieutenant governor
Fairfax categorically denies Vanessa
Tyson and Meredith Watson's allegations
against him in a statement to CBS News
he says his I am able to hear the pain
they have expressed a pain I hope they
are able to resolve and heal from
however because I never assaulted either
dr. Tyson or miss Watson I know that my
actions cannot be the source of that
pain both Watson and Tyson are calling
for a public hearing into the
allegations a legislative aide tells CBS
News Democrats have been negotiating
with Republicans on the terms for a
potential hearing but so far a date has
not been set and they go into session
again tomorrow and both women are hoping
something will come will come of that
and both of them say they want the
hearing instead of the investigation
because in many cases they say the
results of the investigation can be kept
private and they would like to be an
open in an open forum with all of them
including Justin Fairfax they would like
him to to testify as well I don't think
we've ever seen anything like that if
that were to occur yeah I mean
incredible and right now in Virginia
both sides are pointing fingers at the
other as to why this hearing hasn't
happened and maybe now that there will
be some conversation about it we'll see
we'll see the pain